U.S. education has been marked by fierce debates
over whether schools should group students
based on ability.
Critics have suggested that U.S. schools engage
in “ability grouping” to an unhealthy,
undemocratic degree.
So, does the U.S. really do a lot more of
this than do other nations?
Well, a recent OECD analysis is clarifying.
In 2006, across 40 nations, just nine
percent of 15-year-olds were enrolled
in schools that had ability grouping.
In 2016, that figure was eight percent.
Remarkable.
Just eight percent.
And the U.S.?
The comparable figure was four percent, in
both 2006 and 2016.
Yep, the U.S. engaged in ability grouping
at just half the international rate.
It’s funny.
Our education debates tend to be extremely
bitter, with critics of American schools
insisting that our policies should be more like those elsewhere.
Yet, at least in this case, it turns
out that U.S. schools are wholly innocent
of the charge at hand.
Do you think it's a problem if schools group students by ability?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.